okay I'm back I have this little friend
following me now I don't know what I
feel about it I have a lot of things
that can follow me I have this guy I
also have this no I ate him I guess you
can only have as many why does it sound
like I eat them okay these guys are my
loyal followers I have a lot to show
alright I also have this I know
fabulous look at me go absolutely oh
sorry
oops oopsie whoopsie I played for like
five minutes and all this stuff drop I
got this yo-yo and it's amazing but I
also have this key to the jungle and I
also have a hunt oh sorry you can't come
with us mate and I also had this look at
him go
look he can go backwards as well Wow
moonwalking that's right oh my god it
excuse me it's so good
oh wow the corruption is really
spreading I forgot I was supposed to
look up how do you got rid of it alright
well we're going to the jungle so it
doesn't matter because in the jungle we
can also buy something very cool if I
can find it here we go this is the
jungle oh yeah alright so he lives here
now but we can talk to him and by leaf
wings yes
and the leaf wings makes it so you can
fly I think oh my god I can fly I can
fly oh no I cannot fly as much as I want
kind of I can kind of fly does it work
if I'm on the horse it does not work if
I'm on the horse okay that's a shark the
Sharks there's sharks in Terraria I
don't like it I changed my mind about
game okay I get the Sharks out of the
way I'm done I'm done I don't freak with
sharks oh look I gonna have to yo is at
the same time look at that I have two
yo-yos
Jojo okay so we're gonna stop the
Crimson from spreading I'm just gonna
blow it all up to be honest I'm just I
don't have that much gold oh dami whoa
it's a meteorite when did that hit I
think I should be able to walk on it
without yeah this is good even blow it
up one of the fart noises are just so
much funnier when you're in a unicorn
yeah alright so here's the corruption
let's just dig straight down oh my god
we still have so much to go this is the
only way god damn it there must be a
quicker way oh my god I just came back
and there's a freaking pirate innovation
where did this come from they are way
too strong I'm gonna die everything oh
god stop shooting me I'm a wedding dress
woman are you kidding me they dropped so
much gold though I want to kill them all
six percent stop shoot it lady don't
shoot the lady alright this is better
this is my fighting error yes use the
horse can't touch me I'm a lady on the
horse I'm dead and then are you kidding
me
they keep shooting me I'm just gonna
close to the oh no heal me [ __ ]
yes oh yeah oh yeah what are you gonna
do yo yo old a [ __ ] oh that's the
captain oh my god he has so much hell
all right I think I got the strategy
down at least captain's gone Obama is
gone I knew it there it is kill their
birds god I'm sick of these get my gold
back I want my gold back oh god there's
so many okay nothing
oh my god the shooting I hit them who
will win a giant pirate army or a
wedding man
unicorn yo yo yeah oh my god you suck so
much yeah take those yo-yos yeah they're
trying to explosion they're explosion me
they explosion at me oh god they're
broken all right I can heal me heal me
woman heal all right we're almost
halfway Jesus Christ it never ends
Oh God I am NOT going there I've got
another captain yeah more thoughts
Adam 73 percent 96% come on
did I do it I don't know yeah I did it
brah I made so much money from that
twenty eight gold golden what what who
knew pirates were rich dude what there's
a flying ship I never even saw this brah
I don't have time oh oh I was like what
is bombing me no you do not escape from
me so he's still worth shooting out all
the Pirates come on it's getting bright
I need to kill him before two down
no it healed what come back you snake
come on let one more come on
first boss in hard mode I did it I did
it that was a mess did he not even drop
anything cool quite a design oh my god
the evil has been defeated
unfortunately Connor is still alive brah
IKEA power is getting like rich and
stuff
golden piano since things golden chests
brah I'm rich bruh I got three diamond
yeah bruh
what oh my god I'm rich I'm so rich oh
my god I have so many banners a pirate
banner so I got this award whoa whoa
okay all right okay I also got pirate
pants and a pirate sword whoa that's
fast oh my god
Blackbeard the pirate has arrived oh
come on
mithril anvil so now I can craft other
things I guess all I know is I'm rich
now and I can finally buy a bunch of
dynamite oh yeah I got a freaking eye
patch - I look so badass yes I have
played terraria all day I have played
whole day don't tell me I see okay so
what I did my genius idea is I cut off
all the corruption here here here that
was very awkward that took a long time
and then I didn't hear now I'm kind of
bored I'm not gonna lie I don't want to
do that ever again I can't wait for the
comments to say there's a way smarter
way to do it but I did it that way and
that's the way I do it and now more I
don't have to worry about corruption for
the epic okay the only thing I haven't
found yet is sky cities I think after
that I beaten the entire game so I mean
goddamn my character looks so badass I
love it it's the most hardcore character
they were created that haircut pirate
patch and wedding bride on a unicorn
with a yo-yo you just don't mess with it
you just don't
I got a mithril pickaxe I probably need
to remake it actually how fast is it
mine though whoa you see that alright
we're in the jungle we have this key
right it's probably a boss I feel like
that's a boss oh my god gobo more like
go home hobo got him Jesus Christ okay
this is our new house oh god what is
this derp Ling
I don't need darlings look how fast I
mined this mine all day mine all night
and it can't even bother alright if it's
not poor wait what is that
I can't mine it even with mithril what
what oh my god this whoa what oh yes yes
yes rich you're poor I'm rich ten gold
baby
what do I feel like I'm 12 when I play
this go away stink you're stinky whoa
why do they sound like the things from
my minecraft playthrough goddamn good a
game what am I supposed to find in the
jungle then I don't know Jesus Christ
what is that oh it's a faker I got eaten
by a [ __ ] wait the window oh well I'm
angry no I'm not dying from [ __ ]
fishes yes oh yes thank God garbage
don't waste my time
poor I don't really know what I'm
supposed to do at this point I'm just
chilling there's fishes everywhere I'm
done
no fish I'm too rich come on I can't
just walk around with this money hey
Connor suck on my BP Adam I know what I
want to do what happens if I summon
Cthulhu its he actually strong or Oh God
maybe he's different crazy no he's
Normie look at him
haha look at this dude
we pathetic
haha so bad all right I think I have
another one
oh no he's come back I can't believe it
alright nice I do have this which lets
me summon another boss but I sincerely
doubt I'm ready but hey let's try it oh
Jesus I want to get him a horse I'm a
cybernetic organism
dude he shoots lasers like that's not
fair bro he's he's got robot arms oh he
got me with the lasers for I'm not doing
any damage oh this is the tough one
hey Katie you want to hear me thanks
alright back to the front
just picking away slowly but surely you
know is healing I can't tell heal oh my
god you dumb oh I hate her alright new
strategy we made a new little house for
her hope she likes it yeah enjoy your
new house but she's so dumb she doesn't
now to get there while she's still
trying bless her
oh my god actual brain then go oh my god
here you enjoy your home oh god now I
got to wait for tonight and day
oh I think I found one finally yeah my
god come on Oh what all right fine I'm
gonna fight the boss anyway all right I
had this now let's see how this goes
I'm back dude my damaged look at this
damage it's going down too fast this is
too easy
open up
oh he fell for the old trick oh my god
is this a viable strategy
[Music]
talk to the hand
unbelievable I don't think I do enough
damage this is just like a small theory
fine your fault I should probably stop
playing now let's guys say this baby I
just dig my way up okay here we go
why does it sound so evil Jesus hello I
come from foreign land I shut down your
wood shop shop shop shop
oh wait cute garbage are you kidding me
let's rate it bird kill it
birds kill said all they had god damn
they're poor seriously brahman space I
wonder what happens if you go to the far
end again brother this unicorn is the
best thing that ever happened to me look
what I did I separated the whole area
all the way down hey stop stop never hit
a man in a wedding dress
that's illegal they're throwing a party
as soon as I leave in [ __ ]
all right let's talk to the old man
whatever old man not here anymore
Oh No so sad Asian cool party games hate
you thanks for having a party without me
Connor who bought the bubble machine huh
okay if we drink this we can walk on
water
whoa and then I should be able to swim
if I have this there's nothing here
are you kidding me no no yeah
there's nothing here fine don't care
I'll check the opposites I don't care oh
god I so corrupted here as well I didn't
know that
oh no no no no are you kidding me oh all
right let's check what's under the water
yes yes yes that's it okay guys I need
your help
I don't know what else to do smash like
we enjoyed this series check out the
meme review merch and see you guys
tomorrow
hey hey
[Music]
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need your hand
the time where you will face but crawler
is all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne party is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
[Music]
you